for decades and decades conservatives
have been disappointed by the supreme
court's turn
from being a fairly apolitical
institution that calls balls and strikes
and leaves most of the big policy
decisions to elected officials
to an activist body pressing liberal
social goals on the rest of us
now reading miranda rights under the
constitution that was one
thing but 1973 everything changed with
roe versus wade
justice harry blackman and six others
used the due process clause of the 14th
amendment
to strike down a state law prohibiting
abortion
which then took the issue away from all
50 states
and nothing has been the same since more
than any other that case set the
precedent
for the court to act as kind of a super
legislature to impose
a new social order on the american
people
but when unelected life tenured judges
ended up taking power away from the
people and exercising it themselves
that created a huge fissure in america
our framers never envisioned that a
handful of unaccountable
jurists would have such outsized
influence but that's exactly what
happened
now conservatives have been patiently
waiting
and patient patiently working to repair
this damage to our constitutional system
for as long as i've been alive they've
been trying so they've marched they've
raised money
and we've all voted for candidates who
promised to restore the separation of
powers to its rightful place
but often we've come up short too often
justices nominated by republicans
end up evolving to the left
from william brennan an eisenhower
nominee
to warren burger one of nixon's picks to
david suter
of bush 41 fame and john roberts
a bush 43 appointee in seminal cases
they abandoned the principle of judicial
restraint
and joined the activist liberals now one
of my earliest memories as a young
reagan administration staffer
was watching the robert bork hearings
that was back in 1987 what they did to
him
was vicious political blood sport and
republicans weren't ready then to fight
back
well a few years later he warned about
judges becoming social justice warriors
there are two kinds of justice one the
kind that justice
the judges should be concerned with is
justice under law
which means applying the law fully and
fairly
there's a higher justice which is
justice according to morality
and that is really not for judges that
is for our legislators and for ourselves
to enact our principles of morality into
law which the judges should then respect
and apply
well democrats savaged him because they
didn't like the fact that he was a
strict constructionist
while they were motivated solely by
their desire to protect their holy grail
of abortion they rejected his nomination
and anthony kennedy went to the court
instead justice kennedy was a very nice
man but he then spent decades
disappointing the voters
who put reagan in office but
conservatives soldiered on within the
constitutional framework
and we were told that we had to get
control of our own party and then
win at the ballot box to effect change
at the court
well that's what we did and we did it
with trump's victory in 2016.
and now that we have the chance to put a
fifth judicial conservative on the court
i no longer count roberts as one
democrats are threatening to blow up the
entire system
hence the title of the angle right at
the court they claim that if they win
the senate
they'll pack the court by adding new
justices expanding it something by the
way that hasn't been threatened and
tried since 1937
when fdr tried and failed to mold the
court in his favor
let this moment radicalize you
if mitch mcconnell is not going to honor
rbg's final wish we will
the democrats are saying well we'll just
pack the court what would the impact
study
look you've essentially cheated and
stolen over two seats the scalia seat
and now this one
and i think they'd be well within their
rights to do so i think
additional justices need to be placed on
the on the supreme court
this is just unbelievable it's
outrageous
so ruth bader ginsburg passes away at
the age of 87.
the constitution gives the sole right to
nominate her replacement to the sitting
president
who is donald j trump period and if his
party has control of the senate
they have enormous a power to move a
nominee to a full senate vote
period they didn't get these powers by
accident
it wasn't a mistake they got them from
the voters who gave president trump
over 300 electoral votes and who gave
republicans
53 senates and the senators in the
senate
that's how our system works but now the
left
would have us ignore the entire
constitutional system
because of something the deceased
justice supposedly said in her final
days
her last wishes wayne told the voters
decide who will be the next president
before pushing ahead to fill her seat
she said my most fervent wish is that i
will not be replaced
by an until a new president is installed
we believe that brazenly defying the
dying wishes
of a woman who spent her life devoted
to realizing the full promise of the
constitution
the full promise of the constitution is
in the constitution
imagine if we took that attitude at any
of the i don't know 500 occasions when
we lost a big case at the court
or when bork's nomination went south or
maybe after they
horribly mistreated brett kavanaugh
imagine if we had reacted like they did
the democrats would have been screaming
bloody hell
oh and by the way since they don't like
the fact that the gop has a 53-47
majority
they're also threatening to pack the
senate
that's something that's never been
attempted they
can abolish the filibuster they can
grant statehood
um to d.c and and puerto rico
we talk about things like court reform
statehood for d.c puerto rico none of
that happens
if the democrats do not take back senate
what we'll do is very simple
we'll add uh dc and puerto rico as
states that's four new senators
oh why stop there why stop stop at four
come on keep it going
oh by the way it gets worse if those
threats fail their surrogates will try
old-fashioned physical threats as well
we need to be
out in the streets we need protests out
there every single day
now remember what i said back in january
of 2019 about alexandria ocasio-cortez
i think it's a mistake for conservatives
not to take her seriously to brush her
off as kind of a flash in the pan or an
upstart
she's as close to a thought leader that
the democratic party has today
this entire unhinged response to the rbg
replacement
is being driven by the far left of the
party aoc
plus three plus whoever else she's going
to drag along with her
biden was basically hiding most of the
weekend the man doesn't even know what
to do
surely the leader of the senate
democrats isn't appearing with a
freshman
congresswoman on a matter that the house
has zero
authority over he we wouldn't do that
right chuck schumer
oh yes he would would you be in support
of potentially renewing
talks of an impeachment hearing either
against the attorney general or the
president
we must consider again all of the tools
available to our disposal
and that all of all of these options
should be entertained and on the table
schumer's embarrassing himself but so is
everyone else in the party
they're so obsessed with beating trump
and his voters
that they're willing to destroy our
entire system of checks and balances to
do so
allowing the radical left to call all
the shots
and we predicted it here on the angle
poor biden they
can't get control of these people he's
just an empty vessel to be
filled with radical policies by radical
politicians
who hate our history hate most of our
traditions
and hate most of our people he's too
weak to control the young bolsheviks
he doesn't have the sharpness to
redirect their efforts
and now his entire party is going off
the rails
the real choice in this election has
nothing to do with biden
it's a choice between president trump
and the hard left
and this confirmation battle will show
us just how
crazy the other side is republicans are
doing
what they've promised to do for decades
to put originalists
and textualists on the court we've never
proposed packing the court or trying to
add new states
those threats are only coming from one
side
the democrat party is no longer the
party of clinton or even
of obama for that matter it's the
abortion party
it's aoc's party and for that they're
willing to destroy
everything we americans built together
over 244 years
one issue let that sink in for a moment
and that's the angle